good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday it's hump
day back with Jackson Claude original
recipe hope everyone's doing well hey
Jack say you darn hey La of the turd
variety I'm doing well thank you for
asking of the turd variety you know
what's interesting when you ask me how
I'm doing I don't even take the time to
think about the answer I just just say
I'm doing well now I'm reflecting and I
am I am doing well I would say but I
that's it wasn't a genuine response you
know what I mean it was ever it was
there a robotic response you run into
someone on the street you're walking
into a building and there's you know how
are you
never once have I thought how are you am
I good how are you I could be having the
work I could be on the verge of tears
like I could be literally having the
worst day of my entire life so good how
are you no but every day on this show
and it's like I would tell you if I
wasn't good I don't even process the
question I just say I'm good and I throw
it back to you oh my God this
conversation's like really hard for me
because I was like I had a rough morning
getting here
and I was thinking like
look I'm definitely in like you know
like I'm in a little bit of a Curt mood
you know you could say a little feeling
a little short
and it's really all because of how I'm
doing so if somebody were to really
really ask how I'm doing I would have to
tell you which I I it pains me to say
I got my period this morning
is that why you're wearing that outfit
to symbolize the color the new
beginnings
yes I was I wasn't gonna bring it up I
really wasn't even though I'm now like
two years I'm going strong for two years
every single month telling everyone that
I have my period but like you you kind
of brought it you like you you brought
it out of me Jax you pulled it out of me
I guess I guess I did I guess I gave you
the runway to tell us for you to tell us
in detail about how you're doing so I'll
accept it I also feel like there's a
difference between like I feel like I
don't need to know when every
influencer's on their period and US
knowing when you're on your period
because like what we do here is so
personal and every little change in your
body is so germane to the tone of the
show and the episode
thank you because like I'm feeling
feisty like I saw like I was a trigger
this morning by a tick tock oh no no not
by Tick Tock of a comment because I saw
this Tick Tock yesterday that was
actually like so speaking my language it
was just about like this uh generation
of what about meism where it's like
people just make content on the internet
talking about themselves sharing their
stories their point of views and
somebody's always like making it about
them like this is offensive because I
can't do that yeah and I was like I've
been thinking about that a lot and then
I saw this comment today where yesterday
on the toast with Jake Shane which was
such a fabulous episode we were talking
about like what is the um etiquette
gonna be I the era store
and like are people going to be singing
and dancing and like taking videos in
the theater because I kind of like just
want to lay down and watch a movie okay
and people like I saw like uh some
feedback being like well you know not
everyone was able to see the concert I'm
like that's that's okay like I was just
talking about my [__] like what
I would prefer that's I was it wasn't an
assault on anyone who wants to see the
movie like now that I'm that I saw this
Tick Tock like what about me I think
that's what like she called it I'm 100
sure like what about meism I that's
that's that's my vibe today like what
about it not only is it so annoying when
you say anything and then someone finds
like well what about this or that yeah
but it's also annoying because I find
myself like self-censoring and not
saying something because I'm like well
what about the person who this I'm like
yeah just
can we just share and know that like I'm
talking about my POV my thoughts my
experience it's not an attack on you
yeah and maybe even you're talking about
like the majority's experience and yes
there will be people in the minority who
don't have that experience all the time
or whatever it is but it's like damn
can we get out of the weeds can we get
out of the weeds so like I'm just
feeling triggered today and I'm feeling
like I'm gonna be a little bit rude and
I wanted everyone to know that Claudia's
not this wench she's on her period come
on are we out of the weeds yet are we
out of the weeds yet are we out of the
weeds yet are we out of the weeds we're
not by the way well I guess I could
one-up you in terms of non-ideal
mornings okay now this is also another
thing because I was thinking about this
what about me as I've been watching Real
Housewives of New York and it's kind of
they should call it the real uh
Housewives of New York searching for
victimhood like they all have like
really actually amazing stories about
how they got to where they are and
they're using it as a competition like
everyone's like well I only had 20 in my
bank account when I came to New York I
had negative 400 like it's not a
competition like we're all just sharing
yeah
but continue yeah so woke up for a
feeding with Charlie at 5 30. finally
fell back asleep at 6 30. damn Harry
woke up at 705.
and We're Off to the Races
okay we could think about that we could
think about how horrible that is we
could or we could think about the fact
that we are less than a week away from
your book coming out we could and Harry
came out early because he was just so
excited and I'm not even lying I'm not
even lying because I would never like
lie about what Harry's up to but this
morning when I picked him up out of his
crib we sat on his chair and he said
counselor that's him asking for
counselor book so we could talk about
that or we could talk about the five the
fact that you're coming to New York and
you're going to see your family yet next
week is going to be a great week and
that is what is propelling me this has
been the busiest week of my life but I'm
putting together so many fun things for
the launch next week so I have my book
signing at books and greetings
Northville New Jersey next Saturday
October 14th 11 A.M get your ticket Link
in my stories you have to get a ticket
in order to come you have to register
but you just get one ticket bring your
kids it's gonna be so fun does a ticket
equal a book ticket equals book yes sign
book I love when things are just like so
clear like that yeah so you'll meet me
me sign your book meet your kid can't
wait and then I'm also planning
something in the city for the week of
launch that is not going to be a book
signing specifically you will get a
signed book but it's not gonna be like
that it's waiting online it's more so an
event like for the children so cute I'm
waiting to finalize all the details and
then I will share I'm just being vague
because until things are final I hate
sharing because then they don't happen
so I'm really excited about this event
it will be different than the book
signing on Saturday and it will be on
Friday in the city I will be there books
will be there fun will be there so if
you're not in the tri-state area get
your book pre-order it now
camperencounter.com it's available
anywhere that you get books please
pre-order it I'm so excited I'm getting
so excited to get books in hands it's
fabulous it's such a big week next week
that's why actually I'm really glad I
got my period this week that's true so I
could really be fully present and
positive for your big week so when you
were saying yesterday that you weren't
feeling well and you think you're sick
was that just period talks last night I
texted Jackie I'm like I'm not well like
something's up and my back was killing
me like kind of how you like get back
aches and you get the flu yeah and then
I woke up with my period I'm like oh oh
so you're not getting sick I don't think
so I believe it was my period oh good
because I was like you're getting sick
we're coming to town no there's children
involved and that's not gonna work not
to like kind of one-up you in the victim
category but the air conditioning is not
working in the studio like it's hot so
if you guys hear a little breeze on my
microphone like please just bear with me
I need this little fan to keep me alive
and kicking for today's episode we've
already established that fan doesn't
make a sound so great yeah good okay
good then I'm putting it on a higher
level so yeah I'm gonna be I'll see you
next Tuesday today and I just feel like
that's the vibe right now I'm gonna try
to keep my
emotions emotions at Bay because you
know what I wasn't gonna bring it up
like and now I'm reflecting on my
morning so back to the original question
how are you doing you know I'm [__]
tired it's been a morning not unlike any
other morning but just so many things
it's just been a morning
and this is why people don't share how
they're actually doing because it's
meant to be hey how are you good not a
seven minute conversation good thanks to
you but now you know because we keep it
real with you guys we are genuine to our
authentic authentic it's so authentic
and you know this is not to say that you
know us having difficult mornings is you
know an assault on maybe what you went
through this morning we're all just
sharing our experiences maybe someone
nursed at 4 30 and their toddler got up
at 605. maybe that happened maybe so
shout out to you as well shout out to
everyone it was every morning that could
have possibly happened shout out to
anyone who's you know up an atom
I just feel like there's people who
could be offended by that
oh you're right because what if you're
not up and at okay how about okay yeah
no that's a that's a good point
shout out shout out to the peeps
but what if people like lost their voice
and they can't shout
[__]
um
hope everyone's doing well
how's that
I don't see a problem but you never know
you never know
so that's how we're doing
but you know what I'm gonna lead with
well I'm doing well thanks for asking
yeah we're both doing really really well
you know given the circumstances
compared to another compared to what
others you know what we're dealing with
what is good is that we're together
again original recipe
and we had an amazing episode yesterday
yep I was thoroughly enjoying it as I
signed my book plates and wrote my
little curds for my influencers I wanted
to know if everyone else was cackling or
just like noticing Jake Shane's laugh
like especially if you were listening
with airpods like
he had the most amazing laugh like you
know what some you have it too like as a
person you know I'm speaking for my
experience as a person who like loves to
make others we have to drop this [__] I
know I love to make other people laugh
so I I'm very like I'm actually always
really aware of other people's lives
Taylor schrecker has an amazing laugh
you have a great laugh some people just
give you a laugh that makes you feel so
good about the joke that you made and
Jake was one of them like it felt like a
reward like he was putting money in my
pocket you know that's nice yeah you
have that too when you when you go full
canine like we can see all your teeth
and you're like
oh you know that canine yeah like you
have a big voice yourself like I see all
of your teeth
show me a tooth why are my teeth
reminiscent of a canine okay don't be a
victim like I know I'm kidding they are
I'm a vampire aren't teeth called
canines
I wasn't calling you a dog
another word for teeth is canines
excuse me in what language wait wait I
think you're trying to like just talk
about my canine teeth because I have
fangs wait
canine isn't a word for all of your
teeth
not where I'm from it's two of your
teeth are named your canines I guess
like your fangs like you have fangs
molars canines that's what I'm saying
you were just talking about my fangs oh
I really thought it was like a word for
all teeth my bad it's no coincidence
that these pointed teeth are named after
dogs they are called canines due to
their resemblance to a dog's fangs okay
I was gonna say are canines fangs
because we got big canines yes so when
you said full canine I knew that you
were talking about my fangs it felt like
an attack no you know what I understand
you actually weren't searching for
victimhood there I was there I had found
it yeah it's been found it's no but it's
okay I love my canines I actually have
been like learning to love my teeth
except like you know with this recent
weight loss like so many things about my
body are changing all of them good I
can't lie but one thing I've noticed
about like my face getting smaller I got
some big gums I got like I'm a gummy
girl you know what I noticed like now
that I'm larger and I look back I
thought you were saying what you noticed
about me on my calm down no when I look
back on like footage or pictures from
when I was like small dinner
that I have big teeth
like I because now I don't agree
actually now I can see myself
I almost like a stranger I look at like
little pictures of myself and I'm like
oh that let me like go over her I
couldn't see myself before and I was a
gorgeous girl I just want to say I don't
agree with that about your teeth
no but like my teeth were did not look
how I thought they looked
but does nothing ever looks um we're
just commenting on our former selves oh
so I'm just sharing are you sure you're
not putting on your period
I got you coming for my period of
persona
I'm trying to say like you don't need to
make me feel better about it like it's
not a negative or a positive thing like
just my teeth were not what I thought
that they were within my mouth
yeah but you also have really big lips
which you're so blessed naturally to
have and I feel like when you have big
lips like you can get away with anything
in the mouth region I'll just keep my
mouth shut but that doesn't work with my
profession no or your personality no I
have so much to say as a critical
thinker you can't be closing those lips
I've got to share my critical thoughts
so true
well I would like to get into the show
because we have a lot to do today we do
we have Fast Five we have deer toasters
and we just have like General catching
up to do
on the world so I'm down we do so
without further Adida did it do about
how are we doing here are the fast five
stories that you do to do need to know
and the past five stories that you do to
do need to know are brought to you by
State Farm and here 2-4 I would like to
be referred to as turdy from State Farm
if that's okay with everyone works for
me thing is I know Jake's got like a
whole thing going on and I'm really
happy for him but I think turdy from
State Farm could really
take this company to the next level I
agree facts are being spoken so the
State Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price and it comes
with a lot of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you at an affordable
price just for you because after all
life is just better when you can
personalize your experiences so think
about life think about everything think
about your music playlist think about
your social media feeds like so personal
we're such similar girls and we still
have such different needs when it comes
to music when it comes to social media
and especially when it comes to our
Assurance you know you're a homeowner
you're a Tesla owner so you have
different needs like we're so similar
but that's what I love about the State
Farm personal price plan it's going to
give you coverage on exactly what you
need not not what anyone else needs but
what you need that's what the State Farm
personal price plan is all about giving
you options to help personalize your
coverage that you can protect what you
care about most at an affordable price
just for you so you can see more of
yourself and everything you do like a
good neighbor State Farm is there
hair call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary like a good
neighbor State Farm is there today's
episode is also brought to you by kiwico
when we play with our kids amazing
things can happen we're fostering their
sense of curiosity helping them learn
about the world around them and the
kiwico panda crate is a wonderful way to
keep your baby's curiosity growing
through play it's a bi-monthly
subscription for babies 0 to 24 months
built for brain building fun so your
baby can continue learning more and more
let me tell you what I've learned about
being like a Hands-On full-time Auntie
the minutes are slow you know the kids
need a lot of stimulation and it's like
they get through things so quickly and
it's still you know not even noon that's
what I love about kiwico because they're
taking care of everything it's actually
really fun for you and your kids to do
together it's all really like
stimulating educational projects that
are gonna be fun for the kids good for
you for like having the kids do
something for a few hours so maybe you
could I don't know like make breakfast
so here's what's what kiwico's Panda
crate is all about they're supporting
your baby's rapid development in the
first two years of life with
science-backed projects that support
child LED play and encourage open-ended
exploration each crate includes
age-specific products designed by
experts and backed by research to help
babies at every stage learn by doing
what they do best which is playing and
exploring so kiwico's Panda crate is
practical and convenient for parents
every crate comes with high quality toys
a magazine and activity cards featuring
research-packed content and activities
to nurture your little ones it's super
bonding everything is made easy for you
so you can focus on the fun panda crate
products are age-appropriate and
supportive of your baby's growth unlike
brain building play with kiwico's panda
crate and get 50 off your first month
with code toast at
kiwico.com Panda that's 50 off your
first month at
k-i-w-i-c-o.com slash Panda promo code
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Squarespace or as I like to call
it Squarespace the all Inwood website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online line whether you're
just starting out or managing a growing
brand Squarespace makes it easy to
create a beautiful website engage with
your audience and sell anything from
products to content to time all in one
place all on your own terms so you know
it's 2023 you need a website girly
whether it's for your job you're
starting a side hustle you run an
e-commerce business it can be really
hard and really expensive to get a
website up and running but Squarespace
is a fabulous platform that will have
you up and running really quickly it'll
look like a big fancy firm designed it
but it was just you and Squarespace you
can do anything so whether you're
selling e-commerce you can sell online
they also have a point of sale so you
can sell in person by connecting a
square reader to the Squarespace app
where it'll keep all your orders
inventory customer data it'll all stay
in sync with your online store you can
also sell merch on a Squarespace website
you can you know if you're a
photographer a videographer and you want
to have a portfolio you can have a
digital portfolio online they have
really flexible website templates so get
started with one of one of their
professional website templates with
designs for every category and use case
and then customize your look update your
content and add features that are unique
that are going to fit your needs
they also have a fluid Engine with which
is a Next Generation website design
system from Squarespace it's never been
easier for anyone to unlock unbreakable
creativity start with the best in class
website template customize every design
detail and reimagine your business girly
so thank you Squarespace for sponsoring
today's episode
and we of course have a code for you
guys so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain
thank you Claudia welcome our first
story a real housewives of Beverly Hills
Trailer is here Mauricio is bringing up
the Kyle Richards Affair rumors
and Kyle is bringing up the Mauricio
a fair rumors like over the last you
know 10 years yeah so there's a lot of
talk about Affair the trailer doesn't
give us anything in terms of like where
are they now was there an affair are
they Morgan divorcing Morgan question
mark but there's clearly a popping
season within the ladies and then also
this Kyle and Mauricio storyline yeah
there's a new housewife everyone else is
returning except for Kathy wasn't in the
trailer but Kim was briefly and no Rena
is this our first season without Rena I
think so right wow it's been so you're
right yeah because that was the last
bravocon where she got booed and then
fired
wow it's really been so long Chuck
um the trailer looked amazing I'm so
like back in my bravo [__] now it looked
really good Beverly Hills really has
never disappointed it's such a good
franchise and
obviously like the Kyle storyline is
going to be the Benchmark of the whole
season but there was also like a lot of
other really exciting things going on
like Denise Richards making a return and
her only fans becoming a topic of
conversation and Eric of going for the
jugular because obviously she will be
you know standing with Rina okay but
wait I saw uh I don't know if this was
real or fake but I saw someone on
Twitter saying that so in the trailer we
see
Erica bring up uh Denise's only fans
like did you know you can get a naked
bundle of Denise Richards photos for
seven dollars on only fans and
apparently I don't know if this is real
or not but apparently Denise responded
yeah that's how I keep my hands out of
the pockets of Orphans and widows
I hope it's real I hope it's real how
would they know that I don't know or it
was just somebody being creative and
saying like I wish that's what she said
I don't know oh it's definitely that I
know
like really you're coming for someone's
business like let's not go there yeah
yeah shaming a hard-working woman
it's not a great look also Camille
Grammer was in the trailer briefly she
walked into that party I think for the
first time we see Denise she comes in
with Camille yeah but also this is the
first season where Erica is pretty much
exonerated yeah and is back to doing
Erica Tings which I'm happy to see her
doing and it looks like her Vegas
residency is a part of it so I'm happy
to get back to Erica Jane
2.0 yeah like actually this is more like
3.0 you know yeah yeah
um but the major Crux of the storyline
and of the trailer was Kyla Mauricio
it's still like extremely vague what's
going on in real life now with Mauricio
being in the news because he's on
Dancing With the Stars twice a week
um they pretty much have confirmed their
separation which Jake had confirmed yeah
I don't really know why it's been like
such a confusing roll out of this I
think they're confused too like I don't
think that they know what's gonna be
maybe I don't know what's going on with
Kyle and Morgan or not but maybe it's
just something that she's
experiencing right now and then she sees
her future and you know her golden years
with Mo I don't know like yeah things
look different for everyone so I think
they're they're also figuring it out on
the trailer it looks like they have a
conversation with their daughters about
the state of their family and their
relationship which is
kind of wild to have on camera but very
honest but it also seems like her and
Mauricio every time they talk on camera
it's like not very heated it's like
they've kind of come to this sort of
resolution and it kind of makes me think
like the vibe that I was getting was
that over the years like they've they've
had infidelity issues and not shared
them on the show or really publicly at
all and like this is just kind of par
for the course but now it's Kyle
yeah but it also seems like maybe it's
Kyle having an affair and wanting out of
her marriage as opposed to maybe
Mauricio his affair is like no I still
want my family and I want my wife I just
like want to have my cake and eat it too
we can't know until we see when does the
season actually Premiere the season
premieres on
October 25th at 8pm Eastern Time on
Bravo okay thank you like that's not
that crazy yeah I hate when we get a
trailer like six months in a van that's
been happening more and more like it's
month of month of like that's all we ask
for thank you yeah I'm excited about
that also I watched last night I started
Southern Charms speaking at Bravo oh the
first two episodes and I love Southern
Charm it's my comfort show even when
it's bad it's good to me because I just
like like the settings and the people
but I feel like we've lost so many main
characters at this point that it's a
little untethered like who's gone
I'm not gonna go with who's God I'm
gonna tell you who's still there now
with the guys it's always going to be
Shep Craig and Austin Strong and then
you know you have Whitney somewhere but
the girls now were just down to Olivia
Taylor Vanita and Leva
oh my God so no OG and Madison and
Madison who's holding it down wifey
Madison is my favorite Madison but even
Madison is like a relatively new ish no
and it's like all of these girls most
well just Olivia Taylor and Madison are
came on as a plus one of someone like
it's not like they were cast themselves
and they're great I love them but
there's no Catherine there's no Naomi
there's no Cameron there's no land what
about Danny no Danny
wow yeah so I feel like that core of it
is kind of missing and now it's just
about the Dynamics between Austin Taylor
Shep and Olivia that's the main
storyline and it's just not enough for
me right now interesting I feel that but
I really I love all these people and I
love the show and I'm gonna keep
watching but I just need a little more
and there's also not really girl drama
because the girls I just described like
are very amicable with one another and
all came on as friends like it's just
not that crazy
yeah no that's interesting I didn't
realize that Naomi had left because she
was on last season yeah I don't know if
she's coming but I haven't seen a a hint
of her and there's no Catherine we all
knew Catherine right there was no
announcement about Naomi so I don't know
it was just like a little sparse is what
I would say but when you get Paige
episode one love that that was fun it's
so crazy
but like I think that's the best of
Bravo when like certain when certain
cast members from different shows very
organically end up like the weirdest
thing on Real Housewives of New York
Aaron throws herself like a 10-year
anniversary party and Meredith Marcus is
there and it's just like it makes no
goddamn sense but it does
actually it doesn't because this is such
a new crop of women there's no way that
they would have known Meredith because
when they're filming this like it's
hasn't even been announced no yeah no
they probably don't know each other from
the Bravo universe but they know each
other from
being women of the world I I like I it
wasn't believable I don't think that
like I it made no sense why Meredith oh
really that's when you go back and it's
like how Kyle Richards and Bethany
um our old friends Bethany used to
babysit Paris yes with Kyle like that's
just fun stuff
yeah yeah yeah but I think when it's
like really organic like Paige like
that's the best type of or when the
Vanderpump kids like went to summer
house for the weekend like that was cute
and fun so Patriot I think adds a lot to
Southern Charm even though I haven't
seen the season yet no and she doesn't
want to be on the show like she's not on
the show she doesn't hang out with the
girls they were saying how you know now
that they're spending more time in
Charleston she needs to make friends
there she does uh but I don't think
she's interested in really being on
Southern Charm or else she would be if
she wanted to she would being a reality
show reality show is a lot like it's a
full-time job it's also like very
emotionally and mentally taxing so
for your boyfriend to do it and then you
have to do like a second job no like
Craig comes to Winter house like I mean
summer house one weekend a year yeah
it's enough yeah but the show like needs
her they need which that's the thing
when you're a star like Paige you have
to spread the seed you know you have to
be you just shine on everyone yeah it's
true
but yeah no it was nice too nice to turn
my TV on yeah well I'm actually really
excited for Beverly Hills me too
everyone and like that's exciting
excitement excites me excitement does
excite me and I actually really like
this group of women like I know that
there's going to be beef between
everyone but like there's not someone I
like literally hate no like she has her
moments sometimes like I really like
Crystal I love Sutton I would take a
bullet for garcelle like I really to
read like is you know to read yeah like
you know you could talk about her like
like I have issues with everyone but at
the end of the day like I really love
these women yeah no it's gonna be great
I'm excited for that me too
next a little more content news as the
beckhams prove they're the best dressed
family in Hollywood at the premiere of
David's new Netflix stock so David
Beckham is the
source and subject of a new Netflix
docu-series called Beckham that will
be a documentary about his life the
whole family showed up to the premiere
looking stylish Nicola and Brooklyn were
there yeah which was a big question also
Romeo has a girlfriend and they took a
big family photo that's just truly
gorgeous it's really interesting how
they have like very slowly it wasn't
like an overnight thing where everyone
became obsessed with the backgrounds
like we've known about them for years we
loved the marriage and they started
having kids and then the oldest one
became somewhat recognizable it's been
like a very slow burn for them to have
become like one of the most famous
families and it's not obvious it's not
in your face but it was a big week for
Victoria because she had a show at Paris
fashion week and all the kids were there
Nicola in the front row there was
actually drama because Kim Kardashian
was uh at the show and I guess she came
late and they held the show for her but
Anna Wintour is like sitting in the
front row visibly annoyed that the show
is running late for Kim because she has
a show after this and she's gonna like
then it just delays her whole day like
shows I I guess usually run on time so
there's a lot of people talking about
like who was right who was wrong because
there's a video of Kim like running in
like so sorry so sorry thanks this is
supposed to be our next story oh [__] me
in the ass okay everyone forget what I
just said back to the beckhams I I just
love Heather like very slowly and I
think very organically I don't think
they tried to become this famous family
I just think they happen to have famous
parents that happen to give birth to
very good looking kids who got into
interesting relationships I've really
enjoyed the arc yeah nobody makes sense
I feel like when they were little kids
they're too little to be
relevant relevant and also like let kids
be kids but then they grew up and they
also chose like careers in the public
eye and they're gorgeous and they have
this like lovely family and we're ready
for them we're ready I feel like when
the when David and Victoria got together
in the 90s you could have said like oh
you know their kids are gonna be
beautiful and I can't wait to see what
their family does but they just had to
like the seeds had to
grow yeah that's so true
um and they both have done a really good
job of maintaining their own personal
levels of Fame in such different
categories like she's Fashion Beauty
Queen he's Sports King and even though
he doesn't play anymore he's like one of
the investors in that new football team
like he's so relevant in his sphere and
so is she yeah um but the documentary I
saw this on Tick Tock this morning the
documentary is Like Making Waves because
I guess they address this famous Affair
that happened 20 years ago that I was
not familiar with it was an affair rumor
did the affair happen did they address
whether or not it happened because I I
saw headlines that like she addressed
how the rumors really upset her Victoria
Beckham spoke about the excruciating
emotional turmoil she endured following
allegations surrounding her husband
David's purported affair with Rebecca
loose nearly two decades ago the alleged
affair with David's former personal
assistant was during his tenure with the
Real Madrid team in 2003 rumors world
and Victoria confessed those following
months were perhaps the most grueling of
her life in an intimate conversation
during their Netflix documentary she
said it was the hardest period for us
because it felt like the world was
against us we were against each other up
until Madrid sometimes it felt like
everybody was against us but we were
together we were connected we had each
other but in Spain it felt disjointed
the profound pain from that period was
evident with Victoria admitting that she
often felt isolated even from David
equally reflective David struggled to
find the words to depict that crisis in
2003. Remembering how they felt like
they were drowning he confided every
time that we woke up we felt like there
was something else we both felt at the
time that we were not losing each other
but drowning as the world speculated
David recalled the daily Agony I felt
physically sick every day when I opened
my eyes how am I going to do this he
thought the beckons Beckham's openness
in the documentary seemed a testament to
their desire for authenticity they
believed they no longer had anything to
prove amid the Madrid ordeal Victoria
had remained in the UK to maintain
stability for their sons Brooklyn and
Romeo this separation exacerbated
David's sense of loneliness and
isolation in Spain he recounted I got
sold overnight the next minute I'm in a
city I don't speak the language more
importantly I didn't have my family the
couple's resilience however shown
through David expressed how vital
Victoria was to him noting that they had
to fight for each other and we needed to
fight for our family as a part of the
healing process the family relocated to
Madrid bought a home in which Victoria
took pride in yada yada
um so I guess they don't like address
the validity of it just like this
Scandal yeah
okay thanks yeah and at this point they
don't need to prove anything to anyone
because even if he did have an affair
obviously they worked through it and
yeah they are strong and
the proof is in the pudding but it's
also a testament to how long they've
been famous because I did not even I
didn't know about these rumors no me
neither I mean I guess it was a big
Scandal when we were nine you were seven
yeah
nine it was 20 years ago
you think I'm 27. she's 2003. Oh I
thought you were born in 96 sorry 94. oh
I wish a girl can dream
nine nine oh my God
nine
way too many World War II books yeah
well I'm gonna watch this I'm really in
my sports doc error yes and I'm
realizing why I'm interested in sports
documentaries it's because I don't know
[__] about any of these things when they
come out with documentaries about
celebrities like you think I would care
there was just one on like Kanye and Kim
they do like every bra that's one and
it's like I don't watch it because we
lived it and I know what it is but with
these Sports ones like these are
incredible stories
about incredible people and I have no
idea what I'm gonna hear next like it's
exciting it's actually so crazy when you
think about documentary culture like we
live in a documentary obsessed like
every minor and major Scandal becomes a
documentary like you know what's going
to happen as it's happening the way that
e dropped the ball so [__] hard with
each your Hollywood Story like that
should be like the biggest and the best
most uh like revered source for
documentaries but they totally dropped
the ball and then they brought it back
into his crap it was crap it was like
concept
same in the age of social media like
yeah no you had a good thing and you
ruined it yeah I don't know what how
they didn't become like the go-to it's
such a recognizable name like The E True
Hollywood Story if you go back and watch
like any movies or anything like from
the 90s like it's always being
referenced yeah I don't know how they
fumbled so hard I don't know
damn as a network they have they they
have a few flops yeah but this I think
will do well it's on Netflix I'll check
it out when I have time I also need to
watch the Kelsey documentary there's so
many I was just having this conversation
I went on to dinner last night and we
were talking everyone I was like what
are you guys watching and they
Everyone's Watching like every Sports
documentary they're like did you see
break point that's the tennis one right
full swing the golf one Kelsey Brothers
Hard Knocks there's one about the Jets
there's one quarterback yeah oh that's
what we were talking about we're talking
about the quarterback there's also the
untold one about the swamp the Gators
the Apparently until like that's the
most recent Untold something about the
Florida Gators
I forget something about the swamp
is it about Shrek
it could be it might be about Tim Tebow
there might be a little Tebow in there
throwback Thursday but it's not just
about Tim Tebow or else I would have
already watched it throwback Thursday
like I don't understand how you go from
being like one of the most spoken about
sought after quarterbacks in the NFL
to briefly playing Major League Baseball
and then being unemployed like I don't
understand how Sports Works no I can
understand how you go from being in the
NFL to playing baseball but then where
are you now like where what sports are
you doing now I don't know that's there
a lot of untolds are like that like
people who were huge had like a huge big
rear end moment and then
gone like Johnny Manziel
actually it was just the one year
anniversary of when I got you a cameo
for mantai Teo so it came up
in my time hop I'm like honestly that
was a great gift
it was a great gift oh no it wasn't the
one year anniversary I got Ben a cameo
for his thing for uh
our anniversary so I had to re-download
The Cameo app I'm like oh what else is
here I had Carlin from Real Housewives
of Salt Lake City who got you a cameo
mantao and now Lewis lit honestly
Trifecta yeah I would say Carlin was my
was the most enjoyable okay Cameo yeah
okay yeah okay our next story that
Claudia teased but Kim Kardashian ticked
off Anna Wintour after holding up
Victoria Victoria Beckham fashion show
it's hard not to say Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show Honestly by the way did you
see the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
yeah we talked about it it was like do
you know that it premiered like oh a
couple days ago
I thought we talked about it no we
talked about how they had this big party
to like
announce announce it and it was in
partnership with Prime video it was like
really copying everything Brianna did
with Savage X Fenty and it came out and
like nobody knew about it and then I saw
some clips on Tick Tock and it like it
looked demonic like it was like
Community Theater everyone was like
wearing like there was like skits I
don't know that's weird it's like they
wasted the good PR on on the advancement
yeah we wasted the good surprise on you
yeah that was the that was harking back
to that yeah
I wasted the good size on you okay well
Kim left Vogue boss Anna Wintour ticked
off when she turned up late to the
Victoria Beckham fashion show source is
confirmed to page six the reality star
was a guest of honor at Victoria's
spring summer show in Paris on Friday at
the former home of Carl Lagerfeld one
onlooker told page six Kim was super
late Adam was pissed because the show
was delayed until Kim arrived Anna left
before Victoria even did her walk in
front of the guests after showing the
collection because she was late to other
shows Kim who was clad in the purple
gown arrived with Chris and was seated
next to Anna
um and then another Insider said the
Kardashians fashion show routine is to
keep everyone waiting at least 50
minutes before making their entrance but
there's a video going around of Kim
sitting down next to David and it looks
like she's saying I'm never late and
she's like very frazzled that she's late
thankfully like there's a lot of content
that we can like extrapolate context
clues from and make our own assumptions
and not this just being like a rumored
it's a rumor that Anna was very mad like
we see Kim like runs in says hi to David
who's sitting next to Anna she skips
over Anna and then sits down and when
you could see her she's definitely
saying I'm so sorry I'm never late and
one thing we know about Kim actually I
don't know if I can speak for like all
the girls but Kim is like super
professional very Christian or like
hard-working nice to everyone always on
time do fulfill your duties that's like
her whole shtick it's like about how her
work ethic is half the reason she's as
successful as she is because she doesn't
play games like that so
sometimes like things happen like and
sometimes things happen there's traffic
you know elevators broken yeah I think
also at the level that they travel and
move through the world like just things
are slow when you have a motorcade and a
team and you're correcting your look
down to the very inch every minute so I
understand there's nothing worse than
that feeling of being late when you're
not a late person like being late gives
me so much anxiety especially when
you're pissing off Anna Wintour so I
think Kim just has the biggest pit yep
and I'm sure this is something that
probably sets her back in her high
fashion Journey
because I don't think I don't like this
and it didn't seem like there was Repro
after she left early like things aren't
good let me ask you a question
you are debuting a show at Paris fashion
week it's a huge huge event for your
brand
and you can either impress Anna Wintour
or impress Kim Kardashian
think is more powerful
it depends who you're trying to serve if
you want to serve the mass like you want
the masses like know about your show Kim
because honestly I didn't see like one
other celebrity
photo I don't know anyone else was there
aside from Kendall walking right no and
like her family uh Nicole Nicola Romeo
Brooklyn and honestly I follow Nicola
and I you know follow pop culture I
didn't see Nicola at the show yeah like
I know she was there but it hasn't
dominated the way Kim in this purple
dress has yeah of course no Kim looks
beautiful one of her better looks agreed
but and also Kendall's walking in the
show and like Chris is her manager I
think that like there's a lot of ties
there yes for High Fashion you want to
impress Anna but if you want people
really to see what you're doing and you
want to sell dresses you want to impress
the Kardashians right no it's actually
crazy because this is like really all
Kim has ever wanted like I people people
might say this is like the dumbest thing
I've ever said but I I do believe in
terms of like actual power and influence
in fashion like Kim and Anna are on
similar levels in terms of their their
power yeah but also but they're
different in terms of who they influence
yes it's different power but like
they're kind of on the same level like
Anna influences the industry Kim
influences the people yeah
what's more valuable I don't know it
depends on the who you're asking yeah
the answer is different depending on who
you ask yeah and what they care about
and like it is annoying when people are
late and especially like if it [__] up
your whole day afterwards because like
Anna coming to a show is like such a big
deal but I just feel like Anna's always
got a mug on her face like a smile ever
heard of it but I also feel like Anna
always looks upset but maybe not always
is that's very true
I feel like it's kind of a cliche at
this point and it's because she has the
sunglasses and the hair and like the
movie that came out Devil Wears Prada
yeah but I could also see her kind of
just being like a normal girly yeah like
maybe she's just got a good old case of
RBF like I'm not always mad
yeah
yeah but it is a pretty prestigious that
Anna went to the Victoria Becca machine
I know
so I'm glad it all worked out now
everyone's talking about the show
I think it's good
I wish her well Victoria she designs
nice stuff she does and she's like
stayed you know Elite and and
sophisticated for many many years which
is hard to do as like a brand yes
like it's a she has got a reputable
thing going on
she does I need to see what Nicola wore
I'm glad that everyone's appearing
playing nice yeah Nicola Peltz Beckham
show
yeah it's not even like the first thing
that comes up I saw a bunch on Tick Tock
because so many people just take videos
you'll see it in a few weeks on Rails
job no my reels I don't get served a lot
of like celeb content on reels like that
my reels are very like curated Creator
videos and like Mama Tings Mama yeah
Mama creator videos such good stuff you
guys such a good stuff you can learn so
much on reels
are you ready for our next story yeah
it's a little more Kardashian news
because I watched the episode of the
Kardashians and so we need to talk about
this group chat nonsense okay so
Kourtney Kardashian shuts down Kim's
group chat claim that there's this no
Courtney chat with friends where they
send things about Courtney can they
submit their complaints and concerns and
then the sisters have to like parse out
what's going on with Courtney so I think
we've all pieced together what's going
on here because Courtney posted a
screenshot of a chat with her friends
Ali Simon and someone oh pip through it
yeah Simon's husband saying should we
start uh yes Courtney group chat and
basically all the friends are making a
joke that there is no no Courtney chat
like they weren't a part of it so I
think
Kim was talking about a chat with her
sisters called no Courtney where they
talk about what friends have said about
Courtney but there's not a chat with
Courtney's friends called no Courtney no
Kim was like pulling things out of her
ass like for the sake of an argument
which we've all been there you're just
like making stuff up when you want to be
right
um it was really mean
and
I'm team Courtney on this one on the no
Courtney chat or on the whole fight on
the conversation like up until this
point I could have argued both sides
with the Dolce thing but the thing is
it's not about the Dolce thing and it
probably never was like these are two
people who have a deep deep dislike of
one another and like a distrust and so
now that we're slowly starting to get to
like what the real issue is
Kim is is being mean and she's taking it
too far and bringing in the kids is mean
that was so mean that was so next level
and I felt like up until that point
Courtney really like remained cool calm
and collected but there was no reason
for her to do that I don't know what
she's trying to prove like I just I
found her to be like a very
unsympathetic character like I couldn't
take her side
yeah I agree it was too much I guess
Courtney was saying that's what they do
in their family they just like think of
the meanest thing to say like for
arguments right
it's not effective and certainly not
effective when you are sitting there
filming a television show because I know
you're also thinking about like public
perception yeah and that just like
doesn't reflect well it was just like
Kim kept saying stuff and it was just
kind of bouncing off of Courtney like
she was just maintaining the fact that
she's really happy and she doesn't feel
like Kim can be happy for her and
everything she was saying wasn't
penetrating until she brought in the
kids yeah my only question is if it's an
issue between Courtney and Kim like why
is Courtney so estranged from the whole
family like why is Kim on that trip with
everyone that's a good question not
Courtney well I think first of all like
the Dynamics of the family are always
shifting but I think like Kim is really
like the center yeah the communication
center of the family she's the control
center like she is like so close with
everyone individually and like is always
the one making plans like I think like
sisterly Dynamics which we understand I
would see you're a lot like Kim in that
situation like you're always the one
planning [__] and making sure we're on
top of [__] like if we want to plan
something like we go to you so I think
like sisterly Dynamics are important to
keep in mind and I think Courtney is at
the place now where she's like actually
happy staying back like she has her kids
and her step kids and her husband like
there's so much for her to stay back for
she doesn't even care
yeah she doesn't she doesn't have fomo
and I think also over the years that we
saw in the end of Kardashians it was
like her struggling with not clicking
with her family anymore but having this
obligation to film and be a part of the
show and I think probably for financial
reasons too like she needed to work and
now she like has her husband and she has
her life and it's like she does and
honestly like pushes is a legit business
yeah but I think even if she decided
like I don't want to film and I I'm not
going to work like Travis can provide
forever so it's not as dietitical
as it was before and she can like make
choices for herself and what brings her
peace and that's really how she is you
know doesn't want any toxic elements in
her life yeah she's happy to make peace
with all of it and when she used to say
[__] like that I was like okay sure like
stop being so miss but now I feel like
she says stuff like that and she
actually really means it yeah yeah like
she would walk away from the show and
she would walk away from all of it and
she has what she needs to live a happy
life and when she says like you're such
a narcissist like you're so obsessed
with what people think about you and
like I don't give a [__] like take my
parts out of the episode like let
everyone think I actually believe her
when she says that yeah I agree so I
don't know she made a really good case
for herself by like not she she didn't
even do much
she wasn't even on camera Kim was yeah
but it seems like they have this really
bad conversation
and then they're able to build up from
there because they start filming
together that behind the scenes stuff I
guess you'll see she missed that trip no
but I think from here they move forward
really yeah I feel like that was the
editing was a little confusing but yeah
when they sat down for the confessionals
together yeah because I think after the
bad conversation that they referenced
which we saw they realized that things
went too far and they try to work back
from there yeah no and like sisters need
to do that but I think when you look at
it at a glance like these are two people
who are so different who have who value
such different things who really don't
like each other like if they weren't
related they would never be friends and
I don't think you know this is the end
of it
yeah also as they get older they're just
continue to grow in different directions
and that those directions are further
from one another but still you can be
sisterly yeah
but they're just like not as close as
they were
not at all yeah
wishing them well wishing them well are
you ready for our fifth and final story
yeah
because it's got it yeah I was just
gonna take my charger for my computer
and put in my iPad but it wasn't as
seamless as I was hoping it was going to
be so it wasn't Cinema so I gave up on
the effort okay I have enough to carry
us through though don't worry
the NFL explains why it removed Taylor
Swift references from their social media
channels amid accusations that the
league is enjoying Chief's success now
that pop star is dating Travis Kelsey so
the NFL is getting like a little bit of
backlash they should be too hard in the
paint with tailors
right that's the phrase you know what I
realized that's a basketball term my
post oh no that's fine is it too hard in
the pan or too hard in the paint paint
oh okay good because I've been getting
my sayings like all mixed up with my
postpartum fog so
you feel free to correct me if you hear
me speaking nonsense okay because up
until this point like you've been
telling me like you're postpartum not to
come for you on your clubs right okay
don't come for me okay
but if Alexa send for you if I say a
phrase wrong you can just give me a
gentle nudge okay yeah
the NFL went hard in the paint with uh
Taylor references changing their bio
changing their Twitter cover photo just
like obsessing over Taylor and I think a
lot of NFL fans are anti-ip and also now
people in general are being like
stopping so thirsty yeah no the NFL fans
can eat my ass like now it's just like
be cool my God like they're acting like
they're not the NFL yeah so they now
took away those references and they said
quote we frequently change our bios and
profile imagery based on what's
happening in and around our games as
well as culturally the Taylor Swift and
Travis Kelsey news has been a pop
cultural moment we've leaned into it in
real time as in its inter as it's an
intersection of sport and entertainment
and we've seen an incredible amount of
positivity around the sport
who did they say this to like in a
statement to the New York Post
why are they acting like so tacky like
yeah no like why is the NFL have a mouth
yep
and why why does the NFL have a mouth
and why are they running it
close your lips to married men like stop
yeah no they're acting thirsty I agree
like it it is too much I loved it in the
beginning when they were like getting
involved in a fun playful you know way
but like literally
they're acting thirsty they're doing way
too much and now it's like not fun
anymore
yeah it's like you know the teacher's in
on the joke yeah so it's like we're not
laughing with you [__] we're laughing
at you so stop yeah
yeah it was like cool when they did then
they acknowledged it like a little bit
yes but now it's like be cool seriously
like you're Oh serious like Fortune 500
company like stops the nonsense like you
generate billions of dollars in Revenue
like act like it stop acting like you
like are Claudia you're acting like me
yeah right
thank you
literally
um I'm glad that they addressed it and
honestly like I hope they chill out
because it was becoming like a little
not fun when everyone was like even the
NFL like stopped yeah but what do you
think about how many times they Panter
her during the game so I think 17 times
and Travis heard that he was like that's
as many down that's one sit down pretty
much something the thing is if they
weren't panning to her they'd be panning
to like a fan they show people in the
crowd all the time so it's not like
they're taking away from the game so if
you're going to show someone in the
crowd please show the most famous person
there yeah they need to have like fan
cameras like they have at award shows so
the people who just want to watch her
can watch her and the people who want to
watch football can watch football and
see football fan reactions because
sometimes you know also but also like
Taylor should be able to enjoy an
evening out without being on a three
hour camera feed like that didn't stay
but she essentially is because people
have their phones the entire time she's
being watched and she knows that she
knows it yeah like everywhere that comes
out of her mouth she knows could be like
lip red like she has to be
she has to act right and I guess she
could always like turn around into the
box and
do what she wants to do take a shot I
was watching her the whole time during
halftime she went inside the Box nobody
could see her and she didn't come out
for like a little while into the third
quarter like she probably wanted to uh I
don't know like slouch and relax slouch
slouch chew with her mouth open yeah
live
yeah to like she has a secret
chew like you have a secret
great reference
um the most amazing news Jackie is that
today's episode is far from over that
I'm so happy to hear it because we have
your toasters are weekly advice segment
which is brought to you by a brand new
sponsor Nine West which I'm so excited
about Nine West is one of the world's
most recognized brands that defines
Timeless feminine style and translates
key trends into wearable and attainable
Styles I feel like Nine West is just
like a brand that's been around forever
that has been at the top of their game
forever and it's so good I feel like
everyone is it's very hard to keep up
like what the kids are wearing like I
want to look cool is it loafers is it
boots is it more Western I feel like
those are the trends this season and
Nine West is like where you can go at
the start of every season knowing that
whatever's going to be cool you can get
at Nine West and it's gonna be quality
and it's gonna be quality and they don't
just have shoes they do apparel they do
accessories their shoes are really
comfortable I just like I have uh I
don't know if it's flat foot I can't
wear heels like I'm very specific about
what I can and can't wear and I really
like a lot of the shoes from Nine West
they're so comfortable in addition to
being cute I hate when you have to
sacrifice like you have to look ugly but
you'll be comfortable no thanks no you
want Form and Function so whether you're
looking for going out to a work shoe you
can find anything you really need at
Nine West and you can shop their F
collection if obviously stands for Fears
um so whether you're looking for like a
3.8 inch stiletto whatever you're
looking for Nine West as you covered
from head
sits out so again not only do they just
have shoes they have apparel accessories
and of course they're collections of
Footwear and their fall campaign which
is Bound for greatness is really
energizing it's fashionable it's fashion
forward it's fun it's fresh it's
fabulous it's non-west so visit
nywest.com and use code toast to check
out for 15 off your first purchase
that's
n-i-n-e-west.com code toast for 15 off
your first order today's episode is also
brought to you by Jenny Kane
perfect timing honestly because fall is
on its way it's cozy season and our
wardrobes can definitely use a refresh
Jenny Kane is a California brand through
and through and their Staples make
getting dressed easier than ever think
minimalist and effortless but totally
refined when I think like of what I like
my ideal Vibe my ideal aesthetic when it
comes to home when it comes to Fashion
it is like that cozy Northeastern Nancy
Myers Vibe it's literally Jenny Caitlin
Jenny Kane created the aesthetic that we
all like think we look like but we don't
and she actually made it for all parts
of your life whether it's clothing it's
home it's cashmere sweaters it's candles
it's slippers it's like that cozy and
it's it's that time of year is starting
right now
yeah and if you're wondering like where
do you go to get that aesthetic Jenny
can I wore a sweater on the show last
week on Monday I got so many questions
where my sweater is from it was Jenny
Kane by the way their sweaters are the
it item we're obsessed with the Flynn
cashmere sweater perfect for every day
it's a v-neck and the cashmere Francis
Polo is such a cool vintage inspired
staple we get compliments and questions
every time we wear Jenny Kane I love her
cashmere Cardigans I've had they they um
they last really well they're made
really well I've had my cashmere
cardigan for like three years now
everything in their collection is
designed so intentionally so you can
style pieces together without a second
thought they also of course have a
stunning collection of Home Essentials
so find your Forever pieces at
jennycane.com our listeners are getting
15 off their first order when they use
co-host at checkout that's 15 off at
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e.com promo code toast
like getting dressed be one less thing
to worry about ain't that the truth let
getting dressed be one less thing to
worry about
Jacqueline that's beautiful all right
deer toasters our weekly advice segment
we do it every Wednesday where you guys
write in you can either email us to your
toasters gmail.com or head over to our
website thetosepodcast.com there's a
submission box both are totally
Anonymous you can write in about
anything try and keep it brief if you've
written in and we haven't read it online
it might be too long or it might be
boring sorry
um and we do three submissions every
week are are you ready kids
aye aye turdy I can't hear you
aye aye turdy
oh our first submission is about a girl
who's in a bit of a pickle and we're
kind of to blame we're gonna pick a ball
we're kind of to blame for her issue I
don't believe it
kind of need a device kind of just need
to unburden myself because the toast I
always say love you bye to all of my
friends as I leave their houses dinners
Etc well I've been dating this guy for
one month and it's going really well but
last night after we hooked up and I was
leaving to go home I went into autopilot
and said love you bye he didn't even
acknowledge it we just kept talking for
a little and had a normal combo over
text once I made it home so I'm not sure
if I should address it or just let it
lie but so embarrassed okay this reminds
me of a show I can't remember what the
show is but like the people are in a
relationship and like the girl says like
love you to the guy and then he starts
to realize that like she says it to
everyone yeah and he like doesn't feel
so cool anymore so he just needs to hear
you like on the phone with the pizza
delivery guy thanks love you bye on the
phone with uh your therapist love you
bye until he realizes that he's not
special and I'm also I am sorry you know
that that that we caused that to happen
for you because
um I'll take that on the chin I you know
but I also need to know the intonation
in which you said it because the way I
think she said I think she said it like
we said it love ya bye like if you said
it you're fine you're fine like it's
clearly um
tongue-in-cheek yeah you just need to
make sure he hears you say it to
everyone yeah no or talk about like we
can watch a clip
and then where we say love you bye and
then be like oh my God that's why I'm
always saying that like I love these
girls and maybe you know share it with a
couple more friends and get the toast
really popular in your neighborhood yeah
yeah you just have to like subliminally
or ex overtly let him know that it's
something that you say to everyone and
that you got it from the toast like
honestly stress policy honestly like
yeah kick it into high gear just to
prove he's not special yeah easy but I
am sorry that's the thing Jackie we're
so catchy like we're so everything we
say is like so uh ubiquitous in people's
lives it's actually becoming an issue by
the way this is an issue that I have
myself because when I'm on the phone
with anyone like pretty much yes all
family like I always or friends love you
bye like always yeah and sometimes like
I'm on the phone with a restaurant love
you bye no if I have been listening if I
had been listening to the toast in high
school I would have told all my teachers
love you bye it's so true so honestly
thank god um to all of our high
schoolers like stay safe out there okay
yeah no it's an issue that I have myself
as well that I have to keep in check but
I do a pretty good job of like switching
my mind on and off between people that I
love and that I don't yeah and that I
like and that I don't and that I hate
yeah that I don't know really
really our next one hey Jackson turd my
boyfriend of two years recently took me
out to celebrate my 23rd birthday we're
the same age we're saving money it's
definitely our number one priority right
now since we only graduated college a
year ago we were having such a nice
night until the bill came the look in
his eyes was pure fear since it was more
expensive than our usual dates and he
asked if we could split the bill on my
birthday I started crying in the middle
of the restaurant because I was so
mortified he felt bad and paid the whole
whole bill but not happily there's been
unspoken beef between us ever since what
should I do sincerely a toaster who
likes to be taken care of
I understand that's sad why what I don't
understand is why there's beef like if
he understood that he [__] up and and
fixed it and apologized you should be
able to forgive him like I understand
why in that moment it was upsetting but
he did the right thing why is there beef
like why is he mad I think she means
more so tension like they haven't spoken
about it feels unresolved okay so
resolve it like if if there is tension
on both sides and it's not just you
feeling some sort of way which I
understand if you would feel one way but
like why is he feeling away too you guys
just need to resolve it like you can
totally forgive him this is a forgivable
offense and at the end of the day you
didn't wind up paying I'm sorry I have
like a very hot take what she's wrong no
she's not wrong
but you're gonna cry in the middle of a
restaurant because like that's really
that's really immature honestly like
it's really unfortunate it's really
unfortunate but to cry like I don't know
I think it's a little crazy first of all
emotions aren't always logical you can't
help if you have an emotional reaction
or something and like maybe it's a
deeper issue but like she wants to feel
special it's her birthday and she of
course and she felt like you know no and
clearly he didn't like special right I
can even prioritize spending more on her
birthday like no we should have known in
anticipation that this would be a little
bit more pricey and maybe like a couple
weeks prior just to put some money aside
like he wasn't thinking of her like I I
assume that's why she was crying no I
think she was crying because she didn't
feel special and she just like you know
it's we're working really hard to save
money and that's stressful enough but
it's like my birthday and now I'm just
like going dutch like come on that would
yes bring a tear to my eye honestly and
maybe it's like a bigger issue about her
not feeling special enough
but
I don't think like it
I feel like you could cry about this
without being like a big baby who cried
in the middle of the restaurant like
sometimes something hurts your feelings
and hits you sideways and there's no
explanation it's just like I wanted to
feel special it's my birthday like don't
ask me to split it you know by the way I
agree actually you've changed my mind
but you know what else I think it is
something about saving money is so
unromantic and I think it can take away
from like the specialness when you know
we were all raised on like fantasies of
princes and you know princesses and
having everything done for you and you
being completely taken care of but
that's not what real life is like and
that's not what you know how we actually
end you know end up falling in love and
getting married yeah
and the same and it can be stressful too
and so like to be reminded of that like
on your birthday it's just one day a
year where you just like yeah feel
special yeah I feel like there's no
limitation to what someone will do to
make you happy so I can understand it
being a bummer yeah but now but you need
to be able to forgive him because he
didn't realize that in that moment and
he's sorry and he paid so you guys
should just have like a conversation
about it so that you can move on from it
I agree
you change my mind not the end of the
world but you know a bummer
um our third and final submission is an
update so I'm going to read the original
submission hey Jackson turdy I'm a gen Z
toaster who found you guys through Tick
Tock clips and now I listen every single
day you guys are getting me through
college so I'll get straight to it
there's this guy who have been hanging
out with for a while now and I'll go
over to his apartment we'll watch shows
we'll go get food I also spend the night
regularly and he's the one who asks me
over so I don't feel like I'm
overstepping the thing is this guy has
just not made a single move he wants to
be around and I can tell he enjoys
spending time with me he's seriously a
pee jam and he's also super shy like it
took me a while to even get him to see a
more open side to him when we were
hanging out and when we go to sleep he
gives me my space and we genuinely just
sleep he only kissed me once and it was
when we first met and he was drunk but
after that he's just comfortable hanging
out and just talking without intimacy
don't get me wrong it's not awkward at
all we have an amazing time but how do I
break through the cycle of friend zone
thank you guys so much okay yeah here's
her update here's an update on the shy
guy from literally April I would hate to
leave my favorite ladies hanging a few
days a few days after you guys gave me
advice in April the shy guy made a move
I think it was because I changed my body
language like you suggested that I do
and then a few weeks ago Shy Guy
officially asked me to be his girlfriend
I'm very happy and he's still very much
a pee Jam if not even more I believe our
advice at the time was like we're so
accustomed in like movies and TV shows
like so fast like we're all we're all
like we live in like a kind of like a
greedy age it's like why don't you enjoy
this this slow process but also give him
a little you know shake them titties a
little yeah you're self-known let him
know that you're ready but it's not a
bad thing to not be so fast patience is
a virtue and this girl shook her titties
and was patient and she got a boyfriend
and you're building a solid foundation
for a relationship it's true actually
like you guys probably know each other
so well yeah and so once like the
intimacy comes in like boom you're
together whereas I think most of the
time intimacy starts first it's so it's
nearly impossible to like get to know
someone yeah a lot of times they don't
want to get to know you yep vice versa
and it doesn't happen so I'm happy for
you you know yeah to those who wait
traditional cute love story
love that I'm obsessed I hope he pays
for dinner on your birthday me too
um those were to your toasters again if
you ever want to write in it's dear
toasters gmail.com and our website is
the toastpodcast.com both Anonymous
submissions for your girlies that's our
show
that's our show you guys can pre-order
my book the camper and the counselor
anywhere that you get books you guys
can pre-order you should pre-order you
should because you're going to want to
get the book The Day That it drops
because it's so wonderful and you're not
going to want to miss a moment of
knowing the story of the camera the
counselor and if you're
a parent you're not going to want to
miss one bedtime without camper and
counselor
she said it you guys
thank you so much for listening to the
doesn't matter Morning Show where we
deliver the fastest stories dating to
everybody on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up or
also available Saturday
beautiful setting and wickedly talented
we are
amazing love ya bye